the efforts to curb the increase in
covid cases does continue in clark
county
those efforts will have a direct impact
on our local economy
joe mohler joining us now live and joe
commissioners are set to look at
how well large public places are doing
that's right they want to look at
businesses where more people gather like
grocery stores like the smiths behind us
here now places where
more people go places where more than
250 people are hosted we're supposed to
complete a copen 19 mitigation related
survey
this was due today earlier this morning
the survey is part of the mandate put in
place last week
and asked what sort of measures are
being taken to help fight the virus
commissioner tick sigerblum says the
results will help them figure out
what exactly needs to happen next we
don't want to do is to
drastically make any changes that first
are not going to make a difference
and second can be enacted but the flip
side is we want to make sure that
we don't push our economy backwards
the results of the survey will give
commissioners a better understanding at
what is lacking
for larger events or places now the
topic of concerts and other events were
brought up during last week's
commissioner's meeting
as of now it is only employees who have
to wear masks now
back out here live now these surveys
were confidential commissioners will
take another look at
the results of these on august 17th that
is the next meeting that is set up but
sugar blum earlier did say that they
will take a look at these results sooner
than that
if cases do go up even more than they
are already reporting live here joe
mohler 8 news now